on se souvient encore des affrontements
sanglants de la tragédie d'ouvéa qui
avaient opposé des gendarmes à un groupe
d'indépendantistes kanaks
vint ensuite les accords de matignon
sous la présidence de michel rocard
depuis la répartition des richesses de
nouvelle calédonie a été mieux assurée
entre kanaks et caldoches venus de
métropole ce progrès étaient sans aucun
doute à l'origine de l'accord qui sera
signé demain et qui prévoit pour une
quinzaine d'années encore la
souveraineté française benoît duquesne
dominique merlet a dream by nous sommes
à vos dans le nord du territoire et ceux
qui se nouent ici par cet échange de
paroles et de gestes coutumier vaut bien
plus que tous les contrats les
responsables des clans et des chefferies
sont là pour concrétiser une entente est
confiée solennellement l'exploitation de
leurs montagnes à une société minière la
smsp société kanak issu des accords de
matignon qui s'allie aux grands groupes
canadiens falconbridge vous dire
attention le nickel c'est la grande
affaire de la calédonie le préalable qui
a failli faire retarder les accords de
nouméa source de pouvoir et de richesse
il a longtemps été la concession
exclusive des blancs avant d'être
confiés pour partie à la smsp et à son
directeur rappelle jo c'est aussi le
symbole de ce rééquilibrage tant
recherchée entre le nord et le sud entre
les kanaks et les bleus
c'est pas une romance injuste de
retrouver l'histoire parce que les
canards ont été développés en droit
était palpable web en un siècle
c'est injuste de revoir des jaunes nous
replacer au second de ce dispositif
carl icahn a conçu tirait profit de ce
cadeau qui leur avait été fait avec le
nickel ils ont multiplié les embauches
seraient investis dans le territoire
favoriser la création d'entreprises sous
traitantes comme celle ci pascal naouna
est aujourd'hui à la tête d'une
trentaine de salariés et de huit camions
il y a dix ans était l'un des durs des
indépendantistes de ceux qui organisent
les barrages et attaquent les forces de
l'ordre où les caldoches dans les autres
cas le buzz qui sont qui étaient dans lé
ministre de mai puis à l'époque
maintenant ils ont des entreprises comme
ça et là bas maintenant nous on
travaille on travaille ensemble qu'ils
ont besoin d'une plv loup la mentalité
elle évolue doucement et entre gens de
brochon n'arrivent pas à s'entendre et
de fête
l'ambiance a changé non pas que les
caldoches soit devenu indépendantiste
loin s'en faut mais un certain respect
mutuel s'est installé jusque chez les
plus intransigeants d'entre ces fameux
caldoches de la brousse
et j'ai lu dans un journal qui parlait
de destin commun est un destin commun
même pas pour rien d'autre on bougera
pas et on ne pourra pas l'extérieur donc
on a tout intérêt à s'entendre et donc
ce destin commun vous voyez comment vous
voyez toujours dans la france tant que
la française je reste moi je vous
reprends séparer du niveau des hormones
une même vache médias et travailler avec
mes cannes aigle et soyez prêt à des
mesures comme tout à fait il va falloir
qu'ils apprennent à travailler la terre
nous on a appris à travailler avec nos
enfants qu'ils apprennent à la mettre en
valeurs et d'avoir des hectares et des
hectares
car france de bien c'est que le plus dur
reste à faire et qu'en dehors du nickel
et de saman redistribuées en dehors de
la province nord et de ses mille deux
cents fonctionnaires en dehors des
infrastructures cofinancé par l'état les
projets et les réalisations kanak sont
rares
léopold ii j'aurais dû et le sait mieux
que personne lui qui préside la province
nord passé le temps des aides et les
subventions la révolution kanak reste
encore à accomplir on peut pas continuer
demain dans une même nation pour tout le
monde à venir
ben vous les gamins nous les kanaks nous
on veut rester chez nous avec nos droits
particuliers nos statuts particuliers
nos raisins et puis vous les blancs
regardez le droit commun ok d'après les
mémoires où tout le monde mais vous
payer les impôts non bbc à changer tout
ça ça va prendre des premiers c'est ça
la conscience nationale et au sud
noumea prospère bien sûr la puissante
société le nickel a dû se résoudre à
perdre un peu de sa superbe au profit du
nord mais pour le reste les affaires
vont bon train en disant à coude et
fiscales de confiance retrouvée de
dynamisme la ville a explosé
on a construit des hôtels attirer les
touristes
l'argent de l'état ici aussi s'est
déversée